it's the Pepsi challenge except with tap
water I don't feel too good man Nico
often when we run out of water you're
known for filling it up with tap water
without telling anyone
everybody talks [ __ ] about like tap
water it just is half water like three
times a day tap water is safe
like the tap water wasn't safe you can
sue the city for like a lot of money I
don't think it's safe I agree it's not
safe
why isn't it safe I don't think the top
lawyers say what's that freaking white
crust that just hangs out near the
nozzle that's minerals sorry I hurt you
do you have a report on what's in our
tap water or are you just blindly
trusting the city I am a little bit
trusting the system it's not like
there's just like latent poisons sitting
in our water
my first inflation pipes all the time so
it's not it's just sitting there but
well what if the pipes are a little
rusty you get a little bit iron oxide in
your water no rust juice
that's disgusting I've seen a video of
someone pour the tap water on they lit
their tap water on fire there's gonna be
methane in there tap water j-jake do you
drink tap water sometimes not very often
because I don't trust that it's healthy
City not the city of Los Angeles now
here's the thing I do trust the system
I do trust that the water is fine I do
not like the taste of tap water
especially here in LA where do you guys
think they get the water from these big
jugs some of its stolen actually some of
it is some of the like Nestle takes
water from from public springs so it's
our water collectively as Americans this
site is on public land Nestle has water
rights of course they've paid $100 20
years ago for it haven't been charged
and aren't paying market rates of
reselling us our water that we own at
huge markups well the company takes
about 30 million gallons each year they
paid just five hundred and twenty four
dollars to the US Forest Service for the
permit in this case our public agencies
have dropped the ball I'm kind of with
red it's a flavor thing here in the
studio it tastes like garbage the white
water comes either from recycled water
sources or from fresh water sources then
it goes to a water treatment facility
it's gone it goes through billion
regulations people like testing it all
this stuff and then finally gets down
the pipe which are made out of metal so
you're right there's to be gunk or some
stuff you get to our building it's like
I don't think there's things that are
actually harmful but you can you can you
taste that highway that water highway I
think I'm gonna make all you put your
money where your mouth is do a blind
taste test and let's get some water
testing kits
I'm down and I'll know this is the
garbage water it is the friggin runoff
upside-down triangle that's gonna be the
purified water you know through our
normal jugs and then square for that
square
alright boys waters ready
first one up here is triangle I'm pretty
sure I know which ones which
I don't actually like this one that much
as much as I like this one I think this
one is that okay interesting
I could be completely wrong but that's
why I think it's like what mmm this one
feels softer and that that's constraint
right triangle which one do you like the
best
interesting okay you got a triangle and
a square
[Music]
this one and then square and which one
did you like better
nice here we go
that's definitely tap water before do
you like better obviously this one okay
which ones which I think this is the tap
water and I think this is the filter I
don't know
here's the thing they're both acceptable
I would drink either of these I have to
drink tap water guessing which ones
which no yeah
it's almost as many I like this one
better okay I believe it's because it's
filtered then this would never be tough
ones from the water all right
[Music]
so I just had a cough drop okay
square triangle few of you preferred the
triangle so if you preferred the square
here in the studio it tastes like
garbage like I don't even like washing
my hands and that sink up there I'm down
oh no this is the garbage water use is
the friggin runoff the square is tap
after just like I said downstairs I'll
drink it if it tastes fine I used to be
called aqua Bingham in high school
aquafina at the school every day now I'm
I really have to drink tap water we
don't get to choose our destinies them
out what can I do anymore dude I can't I
will say that I liked the tap water a
lot more than I expected to you could
all tell the difference though we're
gonna have so much fun that preferred we
could all tell the difference yeah we
should test the water and see if the
reason it tastes different is bad for
house right here we go we ordered this
on Amazon so did you see how much nuts
is in our water that's what this is
going to tell us how pure is the water
normal tap water is children to 300
parts per million high tap or mineral
springs 400 500 is the US EPA smacked
contaminant level here we go that smells
it oh we're doing alright this is 65
sixty five parts per mil all right
sixty-five Leonard got some good water
right there tap water
22 parts per million 24 - 24 now we
should throw in a Brita and see what it
does that's still half of the mass yeah
yes the mass I mean it kind of makes me
think you're like cuz with like meat
production or even peanut butter it's
like the maximum amount of roaches the
max amount of feces and we're marginally
acceptable downtown Genki LA so I think
what we could do at the very end of all
this by the way so you'd actually send
in a sample of our tap water for actual
testing now we're gonna go the extra
mile we will test out a Brita basic
carbon filter and we're gonna go even
further a countertop reverse osmosis
filter the best money can buy
generally everyone to know how to
beretta works before water in the top it
goes through a carbon filter comes out
the bottom and it is drinkable so it you
plug this in let me show you the filters
on this side whoa
it's a four-stage filtering system
though the first two filters are carbon
and then goes to reverse osmosis and
does a final different type of carbon
tasks drinkable clean water up here and
then gray water in here that you dump
whoa all right let's do it it's doing it
it's actually pretty fast it's up the
ton of it yeah so from what I've heard
Brita filters only actually clean about
five percent this cleans supposedly
about 90 percent of your water let me
give you a living a water Clint looks
like 180 so did better than five percent
but not that much better car some
high-grade military water
Wow 42 42
yeah good water though I mean I got the
flavor and this water is far superior to
sprayed on the gray water this is the
refused water from the reverse osmosis
filter oh it's double well that makes
sense it's all the rejected water from
the reversal oh sweet that water
nanotech meekness like it just tastes
like slightly more minerally it's
vitamin water you like better this over
there it's like Aquafina where they add
the rules for flavor you're insane
are you converted it's a like
convenience thing it's like I like tasty
water but I'm totally fine drinking tap
give these cups right here supposedly if
I put a diet dr. pepper in reverse
osmosis filter will come out as clean
water whole thing
you can pour another hand in there more
dr. pepper I'm very curious dr. pepper
pass filter is taking down to 20 parts
per million
wait that's better than yeah the water
that they use maybe dr. pepper was
already filtered when they made the dr.
pepper Cheers
I don't know what to think about this my
Braden tells me and she tastes like Dr
Pepper but it doesn't that is all just
water in conclusion just kidding
in mild conclusion I think we should
send out a test or tap water
to actually get tested by a real place
and they can tell us what's in it but in
the meantime we can say with confidence
our big blue jar in our tap water kinda
tastes the same Brita filter doesn't
really filter your water much a little
bit it really just changes the flavor
that definitely filters your water and
definitely changes the flavor but that's
it
next time we're on the water guys just
open of the big blue jugs and put it on
there yeah I'm gonna put a link down
below for this guy the Brita the water
that we have links about la water
department all of you can do your own
research with some provided links that I
found also a this is an expensive filter
if you want $100 off with a filter we
got a coupon code down below 800 bucks
so the biggest thing I was missing from
ample water experiment was I wanted to
test some legitimately bad water and
what better way to test then Lake Hunter
after it's been raining what happened it
was like raining all day look at this
that is you're gonna do it eight - Wow
rinkle
oh alright let's go test this water ways
that straight from the puddle let
straight from the puddle to there and
then swirl it a little bit huh it's not
that dirty
how many wait what's the number 51 no no
51 yeah it is rain one that's not
measuring big chunks in your water
because it's using the electronic
electrical conductivity so if there's
this big flakes of dirt that's not going
to change that
it's the minerals dissolved in the water
that's gonna change it don't do it yeah
there's no way I would ever drink this
to wit dude do it oh you want me to
swallow it yes Astri juice feel like I
just drank some street meat marmalade
dude if you show up tomorrow I was like
an extra arm Oh
my stomach is churning I'm gonna refill
my purified water and enjoy the rest of
my day